car jean-michel mépris on va le faire
entrer
nous adorent aller bonheur merci
bah je vous dirai ce que vous n'avez pas
trouvé votre site et vous je pense aux
cages en soute rappel lors du seul maire
était plusieurs à les porter et surtout
ce qu'il faut dire c'est que je sais pas
si c'est qu'ils n'étaient pas laver mais
pu lé des cancers est un point car on
est d'accord
le très bon alors dit la vérité on se
dit tout ce soir est ce que ça vous est
ce qu'un acte vraiment que ça dérange de
mettre des déguisements dit la vérité
ça dépend des régions du sahel je
parlais moi tout le monde me dit que je
déteste ça moi je déteste le déguisement
ou le truc c'est juste ridicule
ouais si c'est justifié quand vous
m'avez fait faire chantal goya je trouve
ça absolument génial affaire allait si
mal parce que d'un seul coup il y avait
une justification ou cp la dernière fois
cette exception voilà j'aime bien par
contre si c'est juste met une salle
perruque à vue soit ridicule et jusqu'au
on rentre son plateau vous dites têtes
de cons les dans une chronique comme
françois viot c'est ça c'est bien là je
comprend pas le projet depuis que ces
moines shaolin
il a une tête de moins de chaussée aux
moines on n'a pas tous les déguisements
non plus tous des petits complexes
moi j'ai un complet que j'aie du bidon
et j'aime pas qu'on voit mon ventre et
l'autre vers le rsa mais il n'y a pas
d'autres où l'on peut se déguiser c'est
comme super c avec lui ça l'amusé ça m'a
aussi maintenant meyrin ge et ben j'en
ai donc lui l'arrêté pas d'origine
dérange pas trop d'enjeux faut savoir
s'amuser
alors justement puis jean-michel donc
beaucoup d'autres ont eu également des
déguisements à m vous a préparé une
compil déguisements et c'est vrai que
parfois on se dit pourquoi
il a une très très belle 3 1 et a fait
les couleurs de la montagne
samedi
les eaux exceptionnelle aujourd'hui
mardi gras donc voilà
[Musique]
les siens
justin
mais
[Musique]
le
angoissant moi je moi je sais pourquoi
on aime se déguiser chez vous c'est pour
retrouver dans votre oeil la petite
étincelle quand on arrive c'est la vie
voilà et vous l'avez toujours et ça
c'est génial c'est beau et qui fait moi
c'est une perruque égale un sketch oui
surtout c'est il faut pas que ce soit
systématique dompter de l'autodérision
et ce sont bien la gueule quand on fait
une fois de temps en temps mais faut pas
que ce soit systématique à la haye à
message c'est l'inspecteur mais aussi
des finances qui vient
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]